three years ago I almost became famous
in a small Mediterranean country and
this is that story it all started in
2014 when the world was a simpler better
place like fidgets spinners weren't a
thing yet I was working here at BuzzFeed
writing posts for the site basically at
BuzzFeed we don't have assignments so
it's up to us every single day to think
about what we're gonna write that's
usually a really great thing I mean
that's so much freedom but there are
days where you come in and you're like
uh you have got nothing I'm dried up
so that's what was happening on June 18
2014 I had no good ideas as the hours
went on I started getting nervous that I
was wasting an entire workday so I went
into overdrive think Aaron think what
did you have for breakfast oatmeal okay
21 things that are thicker than a bowl
of oatmeal that's horrible
who eats oatmeal I told people what
about 30 for old people you have to see
before you die
wait what that's worse who's like an old
person I know oh yeah my grandparents
what can I write about my grandparents I
know that they were all born here except
for one my grandfather was born in Malta
and to be honest I didn't really know
what Malta was so I googled it
I hit Search I hit images and bam there
it was Malta holy [ __ ]
this place is beautiful I don't know why
I always assumed it would look dreary
and gray you know like most of Europe it
couldn't have been more opposite I mean
this place look like an iPhone
background everything is like bright and
colorful the doors are red and green and
blue and the boats in the harbor are the
same colors and it's just like why did
my family ever leave this place well I
just figured out what I was writing for
the day so I picked out the most
beautiful vacation poorni photos I could
find and I compiled them into a post I
figured it was like my duty to let the
world or like at least like America know
that Malta is like a real place and like
you can go there that night I go home go
to sleep you know not even thinking
about this post anymore it's totally
behind me and then I wake up to a
biblical flood of notification
I'm talking Facebook I'm talking
Instagram I'm talking Twitter everywhere
apparently Malta doesn't get written
about a lot especially by American media
sites they were pumped I mean like super
super pumped the people of Malta were
messaging me to thank me for the
promotion but I was like why thank you
for having such a gorgeous country all
this attention reached a point where
somebody started a GoFundMe page the
page was called debt Aaron to Malta the
BuzzFeed girl and to my sheer horror the
page already had several hundred dollars
in it I mean what is happening I had
restaurants and hotels reaching out
saying stay with us it's free or eat at
my restaurant it's on the house this was
all super super nice but I didn't expect
any of it I mean I was just trying to
write a post as flattered as I was I
kind of decided I would just fade into
the background and let it all die down
but of course it wasn't that easy
the next day somebody sends me a photo
it's a picture of the national newspaper
in Malta and in it is my [ __ ] face
this is me in a newspaper on the other
side of the world headline reads
campaign to thank woman for extolling
virtues of Malta this had officially
become a big deal there was so much
attention surrounding all this but not
all of it was good the day after the
newspaper was another newspaper only
this time the writer was not stoked it
was really mean the article was
basically saying
is this BuzzFeed writer and why does she
think she can half ask some post about
Malta and get a free trip here first of
all
ouch after that I pretty much just
wanted to melt into the floorboards
I stayed off the internet for a few days
while the Talking Heads of Malta debated
whether I deserved a dream vacation or
to be buried at sea as is the way of the
Internet
eventually this did blow over and the
multipling just became a story I tell at
parties cut to the year of our Lord 2017
my boyfriend and I decide to take a trip
to Italy as we're planning the trip I
noticed we're not gonna be too far from
a country called Malta I figure you know
enough time has passed people definitely
don't remember who I am I check plane
tickets from Italy to Malta and there's
$35 one-way I've literally spent $35 at
McDonald's so we booked them next thing
I know I'm on a [ __ ] plane to Malta
Malta
and I'm honestly pretty nervous was this
gonna live up to the hype dear viewer it
did this place is even more gorgeous in
person and besides that the people are
incredibly nice the food is incredible
it's perfect
but I kind of felt like I had come all
this way and it seemed weird to not at
least acknowledge like everything that
had happened so I decided to track down
the guy who had started that GoFundMe
page I wanted to I don't know thank him
or buy him lunch or like start a
campaign to get him to America I don't
know what I was doing we decide to grab
lunch
he takes us to this little Maltese deli
we're hanging and I'm thanking the guy
Chris for being so kind
suddenly it's me what's his for tear
down looks at me and he says she would
have never googled my name
I stopped chewing and I'm like no was I
supposed to Google your name he says so
you don't know who I am I say I hope not
a murderer
then he asks do you have like 20 minutes
after lunch and I tell him yeah I'm
totally free I honestly don't know what
I'm doing here in the first place so I
have zero idea what's about to happen we
walk from the deli to this Plaza and
there's this big
stately building that I'd actually walk
past before but had never thought about
Chris turns to us and he says this is
the office of the prime minister oh cool
okay maybe he's gonna take us on a
walking tour but then Chris says look
we're gonna go inside before we can even
ask what's happening Chris says to us
this was my great uncle's office I'm
starting to put two and two together and
he says he was the Prime Minister of
Malta okay cool we just had lunch with
this dude who's great-uncle was the
supreme ruler of all of Malta and now
we're going into this fancy ass building
dressed like lunatics we walk up the
steps which have cannons pointing at us
from either side by the way this is the
Maltese equivalent of the White House
and we're just waltzing in inside it's
exactly what you think vaulted ceilings
suits of armor my boyfriend and I are
doing that thing where we're just
giggling and saying [ __ ] a lot [ __ ]
it's like Obama been here actually no
Obamas never been here wait Obama has
never been here and I've been here
that's like somehow even cooler to me 20
minutes ago I'm eating tuna in a deli
and now here I am standing looking at
the highest desk in all of Malta the
last thing they showed us was the roof
which had the most incredible view of
the entire city of Valletta and we're
standing up there talking laughing
basking in the Sun and it hits me the
only reason I'm on top of the Prime
Minister's office in the country where
my grandfather's from looking out on
this gorgeous country is all because I
didn't know what to write for work one
day
[Music]
you
[Music]